welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
i interviewed tom bill you in this
episode
tom billus a serial entrepreneur
producer director
and founder and host of the popular
podcast and media company impact theory
he's also the co-founder of the billion
dollar brand quest nutrition
i had a great time talking to tom i use
this podcast to interview people and
basically try and figure out the keys to
success and then copy them
so i found out about tom's work habits
how he balances work and home life
and the sacrifices he's made to achieve
his goals we discussed his choice to not
have children in some detail
we spoke about striving for goals the
importance of having the proper mindset
learning from failure i found out how
tom prepares i don't know i got a little
irish there first i found out
how tom prepares for his podcast
interviews and the team structures and
habits that impact theory
and then we also covered health and
mindset how to manage negative self-talk
and more
this episode is full of goodies and tom
was so humble to speak with given how
insanely successful he is
it was great this episode is brought to
you by
true local true local is the company i
get my meat from
i'm super picky about the quality of
what i eat because if you only eat one
thing
and it doesn't taste good life would
suck you can go to trulocal.ca to make
yourself a custom box
they have any meat you want plus some
organs
if you want that i like their grain fed
beef lamb turkey
and wild salmon i think that's the
tastiest but i haven't tried any of the
spiced meat or pork yet
you can also get some vegetables on
there now too they connect with local
farmers and then ship you
their stuff so it's super simple for you
and it's great for keeping local farmers
working
and getting people access to high
quality sustainably raised meat
tru local.ca code mp
for free steak so true local knows their
investment into my podcast is worth it
as well
this episode is also brought to you by
ground news
and a political news app interested in
giving you the full story regardless of
your political ideology
i know you all write poker out there in
other words
it's a comparison platform for you
guessed it
news so rather than trying to find an
unbiased news platform
which is virtually impossible ground
news will compare how sources from
across the political spectrum are
covering a story
if 2020 has taught us anything it's that
the stories we get
are so manipulated it's hard to trust
anything ground news helps you see
whether
or how outlets are manipulating a story
to fit an underlying narrative
they have an app called ground news for
your phone so obviously you can check
that out
i recommend downloading the free ground
news app and browser extension
you can click on the link in the
description below or go to ground
dot news isn't that cool
instead of a com they got a dot news i
wish i could have had michaela dot
peterson
anyway that's ground.news thanks for
sponsoring the episode and showing the
bias around articles
if you want to see my clips from the
podcast because you have no attention
span remember to subscribe to this
channel and to my podcast clips channel
which is linked
in the pinned comment or available at
michaela peterson clips if you type that
into youtube
hope you like this episode as much as i
[Music]
did
[Music]
tom bill you welcome to my podcast thank
you for having me i'm excited to be here
thank you so much for coming on i know
you're a very busy guy you have one of
the biggest podcasts out there
that that is very kind thank you um i
really do enjoy doing these so carving
out time can it's time to be tricky but
it's always fun when we can pull it off
well i appreciate you coming on um for
for anyone who doesn't know who you are
could you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
yeah for sure so
um i started out wanting to be a
filmmaker
and i had a feature film that i wrote
turned into something that i was not
very happy with
i meet these two very successful
entrepreneurs and they said look man you
come into the world with your hand out
if you want to control the art you have
to control the resources
so why don't you come with us and get
rich we're going to start this tech
company
and uh you seem pretty sharp we need a
copywriter when you come join us i
thought yeah yeah that that sounds about
right
get rich yeah uh so thought it would
take 18 months
it took 15 years but it did work and so
the company we
ended up doing multiple companies but
the one that was a huge success that
most people will
know me from is a company called quest
nutrition
we ended up selling that for a billion
dollars i exited that back in 2016
and started a new company which was what
all of this was for in the beginning
which is a media company
called impact theory and now in terms of
being a personality online
impact theory the show the interview
show is probably what i'm most
recognizable for but
i don't think of myself uh as an
influencer
or you know a voice um i think of myself
as somebody
trying to become the next walt disney
and so what i think about about 60
of my time is on the studio side of what
we do at impact theory
so we're working on writing comic books
movies tv shows
and we also do um the unscripted side so
from social stuff like my podcast impact
theory
um to truly like on tv
reality show type stuff so that's me in
a nutshell
i had no idea about uh some of that
other stuff so you do
production yes so the funny thing is
the the whole reason that the company
exists is to make
that type of content fictional content
aimed at kids 11 to 15 years old that's
our sweet spot
and as of right now that's probably the
thing we are least
known for um but that is literally the
reason the company exists
okay um let's start with well i'm just
gonna shoot a whole bunch of questions
at you
yeah let's do it can we start with for
people who
want to do something entrepreneurial or
you know make money or be successful um
how do you start how did you start like
do you ever
have to have a certain mindset or like
what are the steps in becoming
successful well michael i'm very glad
that you said mindset so
um yes if so i don't believe that people
are
born or um you know sort of meant to be
anything i think that we are as humans
the ultimate adaptation machine and
there's no question we're not blank
slates so everybody's going to have
certain things that they're good at
that they get what i call
disproportionate returns so for me
that's always been verbal ability
if i put time and energy into
extemporaneous speaking i'm gonna get
bigger rewards than maybe somebody else
but at the end of the day i definitely
was not a born entrepreneur and so
my goals mandated that i get good at
business
and therefore i put a bunch of time and
energy into getting good a business
um so for anybody out there who is a
budding entrepreneur that it
may be um daunted by
the idea that oh i'm never going to be
as good as steve jobs or an elon musk or
you know somebody who was born an
entrepreneur
i will just say that my favorite quote
i say this all the time now is you can't
make a racehorse
out of a pig but you can make a really
fast pig
so even if you don't have natural
entrepreneurial instincts which i do not
you can still
build a big and thriving business um so
it really is about skill set
so if you want to be an entrepreneur you
have to first figure out what is
the reason that your company exists
what's its mission its purpose and then
what skill set will
you need in order to fill that and i
would just say at the highest level if
somebody wants to be a ceo
type entrepreneur you really have to
have the ability to create momentum
now to me momentum is all about not just
moving
quickly it's about getting a large group
of people pointed in the same direction
and moving quickly so there's going to
be a lot of leadership stuff
it's going to be finance there's going
to be organizational structure but it's
all
skill set so if people are willing to
march down the path of learning how to
do that
that's going to be the first step but i
would just say decide what your product
is
take action immediately make a lot of
mistakes
truly mistakes are going to teach you
what you need to learn and as long as
you're not paralyzed
by the fact that you aren't yet good
enough to do what you want to do
and that that's going to be a process
then you'll be fine but you just you've
got to get yourself
moving and obviously we could go on and
on and on for hours i'll leave it at
that and if there's a thread you want to
pull on
i can go deeper on any of that stuff so
goal set aim at something and then work
towards it
no question yeah it's what i call the
physics of progress so
if you want to build a business first of
all
accepting that you in the beginning you
just won't know enough you won't have
the right team
you won't be aimed at the right segment
of your audience you won't understand
your audience well enough
but you're never going to think your way
to those realizations you're going to
have to just
get in the mix of it feel it figure out
what's really working you thought that
product was going to sell but actually
product b
sells far better and so you begin to
fine-tune things
it's really the tolerance for risk the
willingness to get in there and to
understand
failure the way that a computer system
or ai
thinks of failure in ai they don't refer
to a failed experiment as
a failure they refer to it as a sample
so you're getting a data sample
so you budding entrepreneur you do
something you fail it's very
embarrassing your parents are now
panicking your friends who are getting
wealthy working for somebody else are
making fun of you
in that moment if you can stay centered
and say this is a process this is a game
of acquiring enough samples
that i get the information that i need
to actually build a business that works
then you'll just keep going you keep
learning so
what has made me successful as an
entrepreneur is my ability to
to regulate my emotions so i can
have a disruption that makes me feel
badly about myself where
what am i doing with my life why am i
here i'm not smart enough to pull this
off right that moment for me is
happens and it happens a lot but it is a
very
narrow period of time and because i can
re-center myself very quickly soothe
myself
i can get back in the game and say okay
what did this failure teach me
then you know as henry ford says failure
is merely the opportunity to begin again
more intelligently
it's like you you take that lesson and
now you move forward
but if failure
weakens your resolve you're never going
to make it so it's a
you know it comes back to what you said
in the beginning it really is mindset
okay so when you have an idea and it
doesn't work out is there a way that you
separate that from your self-worth do
you do something like that like how do
you
how do you stay positive if you've been
working on one project and then it turns
out
the market doesn't like your project
maybe your project's a bad idea but that
wasn't what you were thinking at all for
i don't know
five years so how do you say you know
maybe i don't know that wasn't me
or you know i can continue how do you
continue after that kind of thing
so people have to understand that ego
is incredibly powerful and the goal is
not to be ego-less
the goal is to build your ego and your
self-esteem around something that is
anti-fragile
so naseem taleb wrote a book called
antifragile and he said look we have a
word for things that are tough that are
resilient you can beat the hell out of
them and they keep going
but we don't have a word for something
that as you strike it it actually grows
stronger
and he said i'm going to coin a term
anti-fragile that the more you assail a
system
the better it gets now the example that
most people use
is the immune system now i know that you
have a relationship with the immune
system that may make it seem like
that's a great example but uh it's
in general a pretty good example so the
immune system
left unchallenged actually gets weak the
immune system challenge though
grows strong and that's you want to
build your self-esteem
around an element of your personality
that if it were attacked by your own
inner critic
by somebody on the outside by all the
failures that are absolutely going to
befall you
then you'll move forward if that's
actually making you more powerful the
only one that i can come up with and i'm
certainly open if somebody has more
is to build your identity around being
the learner
yeah so for instance if somebody were to
like my own critical voice is always
that i'm too stupid right you're just
too dumb for this you're never gonna be
able to pull this off okay cool
so then i say all right well if i'm dumb
in what way
because i have what i call the only
belief that matters and the only belief
that matters is that the average human
is designed to learn okay cool what does
that mean exactly
learning is you go and do something you
put time and energy into it and you are
rewarded with getting better
at that thing so you now have a skill
that you didn't previously have
you can ride a bike when you couldn't
ride a bike before you can work with
excel you couldn't work with excel
before
you can speak in front of a crowd you
couldn't do that before you can lead
people you couldn't do that before
and now all of these skills have utility
and that's where i think people fall off
they think they go take a speaking
course
to be able to say i took a speaking
course they go to college to be able to
show a diploma they read a book to be
able to say they read it
instead of saying i'm doing all this
stuff so i can do something somebody
else cannot do
so building a bridge if you don't know
how to actually build a bridge if you
don't have the skill
the bridge falls it collapses people die
gnarly situation whereas if you can
build a bridge that actually stands you
can actually link
two physical masses of land that are
separated by water or
a crevasse whatever i mean that that to
me is one of those where it hits me so
hard i look around and i'm like
is everybody else getting this like
skills let you
do [ __ ] and it lets you do really cool
[ __ ] and it lets you build a company
somebody else couldn't build that lets
you outperform your competitors
but ultimately it comes down to turning
potential
into actual usable skills and somewhere
in the human psyche that all gets lost
so if you build your self-esteem around
that one act
i'm gonna take my potential i'm gonna
turn it into usable skills
and i'm going to champion myself cheer
for myself every time i do that so
failing doesn't matter
i it doesn't affect my self-worth
because my self-worth is tied to my
willingness
to say i made a mistake i'm not yet good
enough at this
i'm going to apply energies to get
better at this if it's important enough
to me
and that that process of hey i actually
did screw that up
hey i really am not good enough but i'm
a badass
because i'm willing to recognize that
what i call staring nakedly at my
inadequacies
i'm gonna stare nakedly at my
inadequacies decide which of those i
have to shore up with usable skills
in order to achieve my goal and you just
loop on that process
so if my own voice tells me that i'm
dumb i'm just like in what way so i know
where to go get a skill if somebody else
tells me that i'm a [ __ ] hey in what
way maybe i'm actually blind to
something you're about to tell me
and i can make it better so i don't
value myself for being right
i value myself for finding the right
answer and that
that changed everything in my life
that's like the one sort of
realization that is a demarcation point
in my life where everything before
realizing
oh i don't need to be good smart right
worthy i just need to be able to
figure out how to pull this thing off
and always be willing to admit when i'm
wrong
it was a solid answer i found i
i started working for my dad in 2018
when he kind of exploded and i was
running
social media and coordinating between a
lot of different people that you meet
when
you have the reach that somebody like my
dad has
and i found that if i started
conversations with
hey i just started and i really have no
idea what i'm doing
but this is what i need to learn and i
was talking to people i was talking to
ceos
and if i started the conversation like
that it went really smoothly
because i'd listen i'd be attentive and
i'd learn
and there wasn't as much irritation
because you would assume
if you're talking to someone and they
don't know what they're doing people
especially
you know c-suite-level people can get
irritated but i find
if you talk to them in a way where you
admit that you're learning
it's a lot more helpful than pretending
you know what you're doing when you
don't because it's
really easy to see through that yeah
very well said i think
people underestimate look there is a
personality type that
would lord that over you and will love
um to
be bigger and better than you because
you don't know they're pretty small
compared to the number of people that
are like oh [ __ ] like hey i worked
really hard to figure this thing out let
me help you
um always tell people your dreams always
tell people what your
you need to know you will be shocked at
the number of people that have some
piece of the puzzle that you need
and that are so excited to give it
because there's something innate
at least to a certain subset of
personality types
that love to teach what they've learned
and so
you're doing something that puts them in
a position to feel good and then you get
something that turns into usable skill
it's but you have to have the
you have to build your ego around
something other than being smart
yeah and yeah it does throw a compliment
at the other person too if you go
i don't really know what i'm doing but
i'm trying to learn from you uh people
are much more willing to teach because
they're like yeah well i do kind of know
what i'm talking about
here's what i've learned absolutely true
uh okay i have uh
you don't have to get into this if you
don't want to but you you mentioned that
you have an inner voice that says i'm
dumb
and from the outside perspective
that would not be even close to the top
of my concerns for you
so do you have any idea why
that's your inner voice i do so
um have you ever seen the movie amadeus
yes when i was five and it just
traumatized me
that thank you i have to say i've often
wondered what it would be like to grow
up with jordan peterson as a father and
so this will be an interesting
conversation jumanji
a lot of phobias jumanji for spiders uh
dante's peak for volcanoes and amadeus
was just horrifying
there were some videos i saw when i was
a little bit too young i would say
but yeah taking in amadeus at five would
be a trip
uh so i took it in i don't know probably
when i was 15 or 16 something like that
and
it there's a character in it named
solieri and he is a real character in
real life
and was a contemporary of mozart and
he in the movie he has this lamentation
to god and he said
why did you make me just good enough to
recognize that i'll never be as good as
mozart
you could have made me totally skillless
and then i could just appreciate mozart
but you made me you put me right in this
sweet spot where i can
recognize his brilliance and i thought
oh my god like i actually have the
chills now
that that is how i have felt my whole
life now trust me when i say that
from a functional perspective i i don't
worry about this is not a problem in my
life
but if you want to know what i had to
get over in my mid-20s
that was what i had to get over was i
felt like i was just smart enough
to recognize i was never going to be
elon musk einstein
steve jobs like people that had just
some like
innate insane gift that then they had
slathered on top of that
decades of really hard work and so going
back to that analogy of
you can't make a racehorse out of a pig
right you could put me with physics
all day long i'm never going to give you
the insights of a stephen hawking or an
einstein
but once i fell in love with the idea of
my whole life would be unrecognizable if
i just focused on being a really fast
pig and then in the places where i
actually
am a racehorse to leverage those
to tremendous outcome and so that's
really what my life has been about so
i don't think i don't think and your dad
would know far better than i but i don't
think you can ever
get rid of your negative voice like i
just think it's an
innate part of the human brain like that
is just the way that it is
and you can learn to use it you can
learn to not be paralyzed by it so for
me
it's a sort of a mental jujitsu thing
when
my voice coughs up you're just not smart
enough to pull this off
i say all right cool that's a habit loop
trigger to remind myself that all that
really matters
is skill acquisition have i reached the
limit of my ability to acquire skills in
the area that i need to to move forward
if the answer is yes go
hire somebody if the answer is no then
keep pushing my skill set
because i don't value myself anymore for
being smart so
realizing that i'm never going to be the
smartest person that ever lived
sad but true that i just it doesn't
damage my sense of self-worth
and that becomes really important though
when you think about
so i try to tell people this the point
of life
isn't money as somebody who chased money
for a very long time i can assure you
won't touch how you feel about yourself
as much as you think it might so
money is not going to help you fame
isn't going to help you accolades aren't
going to help you none of that is going
to change the one thing that matters
which is how do you feel about yourself
when you're by yourself that matters
your entire life is about
that question and once you stop valuing
yourself for being smart and you value
yourself for this sincere pursuit of
greatness or excellence
or just translating that potential into
actual skill set then
you know look you still have ups and
downs in life things are going to be
hard there's going to be emotional
turmoil all that
but man can you get back to center
really really fast
yeah i think there's there's also a
problem with
people who are insanely smart like
genius level
because i don't know how easy it is for
people like that to communicate
with other people i've thought about
that a bit too and it's like i've taken
physics in school and i've taken some
courses and
there are some things that i can tell
that i'm not smart enough to
understand as well as somebody else per
se
physics is an example i find physics
very difficult
but the upside of that is i think the
closer you are
to average it's possible and this is
just a guess but it's possible that it's
easier to communicate with other people
because
once you get to the kind of the edges uh
it's hard to find friends and people who
understand you i would assume
would you trade it
i i don't know
i don't think i would like i've thought
about that would i add on like 15 extra
iq points what would it be like what
would i be able to understand
and i probably probably i would
but i don't think it would make
communicating with other people
any easier and i don't think it would
make me happier so it might be something
i regretted later
you'd trade it though huh well 15 points
is easy yes i would definitely take 15
points are you thinking like 30
or 45 50 50 is sort of the number i have
in my head because at that point you're
you're a historical anomaly at that
point like if i were 50 points higher
than i am now that would
surely put me at a minimum sort of at
the the bottom rung of genius
um and possibly more if you know to set
sort of humility aside for a second
50 points of iq goes into the territory
of
i now understand things about the world
that other people do not understand
yeah and the only thing so 15 is easy
because i would still find it very easy
to relate to my wife
who is my absolute everything 50 gives
me pause
because i am so into my wife that i
wouldn't want something that i felt
diminished
my connection with her in any way and i
think that is you put your finger very
quickly on the one sort of real concern
is
at the end of the day being the smartest
person that ever lived is
would be amazing i'm not denying that
but
loving deeply and having a human
uplift you and to share a life with
somebody is the greatest joy
i have ever known so i'm not certain
enough
that it would be worth the trade that i
would put my marriage at risk
yeah i feel like i just i already have
i'm a fairly volatile person for
a number of reasons uh i think my health
contributed a lot to that
and it's something i'm working on but i
i already have a difficult time with
people who
think they understand something and are
talking to me and don't
and i don't have the patience to explain
it it depends on the topic
but a lot of the times i'm lacking the
patience to explain it properly
and i think if i you know bumped myself
up in iq i'd just be irritated all the
time at
everybody who didn't understand what i
understood because it'd be so much
easier to understand things quickly but
then maybe you can also
i also like have you had a a professor
or something that
has been studying one topic for so long
that they're so far beyond you know
first-year students
that they can't communicate their ideas
effectively
um i don't remember having anybody that
had lost the ability to communicate i
know
well what you are talking about um i
think we all fall prey to that in our
areas of expertise
yeah i often have to remind my wife my
wife thinks of herself as average in
every area and in some areas of course
she is average but there are certain
areas like logistics where my wife is
inhuman and i look at her like how did
you just think through all the
permutations in like seven
seconds and for her it gets very
frustrating to deal namely with me
because it i'm really like i i assure
you
i'm trying to like follow all the
different ways you've thought through
this
and so i can see her struggle sometimes
with
if she thinks of herself as average then
is the other person just being
obstinate but once she recognizes oh
yeah this is one of those things where
i'm i'm truly
um i just have a much much deeper skill
set than somebody else
if she remembers that then she can you
know cue into patience and
help walk the person through so you do
have to be very careful as you move
through things where you are an expert
versus you aren't
if you don't adjust your thinking about
other people as you go
can lead to the friction you're talking
about yeah
yeah definitely uh okay so
how many do you know ballpark area how
many uh
guests you've spoken with on on impact
theory
uh we have to be approaching
500 at this point yeah that's got to be
close to that
that's a ton of connections so do you
haven't any particular ones that
stood out oh for sure goggins was the
one
that probably impacted me the most so
my journey in life has been to toughen
up so
i was a soft kid nobody
taught me to be tough there were no
coming-of-age rituals where i was
taken out into the woods and had my
teeth kicked in or circumcised at 14
with no anesthetic you know things that
like
look they are barbaric but are they also
useful
um and because i didn't have any of that
i i had to learn to get
tough and
diving into goggins world and seeing
that even
by that point i had certainly gotten
much tougher than i had been
seeing like how far it can be pushed and
the transformation that he's had in his
life that
that was awe inspiring and so you need
to only show me a photo of goggins and i
can you know do 10 more pull-ups or you
know whatever get that
extra bit of juice um he's very very
incredible and then
the neuroscientists often are the ones
that i am
just so so grateful to have them on my
show
people that have taught me so much about
myself because we're having a biological
experience
and to not understand your own biology i
think puts you at a great disadvantage
so i've had
moran surf on david eagleman vs
ramachandran vs ramachandran who taught
me more about the brain than anybody
else
those were i mean just days i will never
forget
okay uh how do you two two questions how
do you prepare for a podcast
because talking to 500 people that's a
lot of preparation and it depends on the
podcast host but some people just step
right in do you do a whole bunch of
background research do you read their
books like
what goes into behind the scenes yeah
secretly i want to not have to do
any of it like i want to be able to just
roll up and shine and like hey
yeah but that is not my skill set so
i am part of my skill set is i'm just
willing to do more work than other
people
i'm i have structured my life in such a
way that it appears that i have more
time than other people
i don't have distractions my wife is my
business partner
so that'll let's get into that next oh
it will be a glorious conversation okay
um so i do a lot of things to make sure
that i
can sort of out compete just by throwing
more time at something
and then i learn very early on to trust
my instincts so if somebody makes an
offhanded comment in their book or
in a podcast somewhere i'm like ooh
that's interesting i want to push on
that so even though that's not the topic
of the book or whatever
i'm going to chase that down so i read
their book for sure
i watch as many hours of their
youtube videos or podcasts as humanly
possible
i listen to things sped up so i can take
in a lot of information very quickly
and by knowing them
as well as i do coming into the
interview i can go wherever
they want to go and i can also steer
them away from the [ __ ] that i know that
they're going to say is boring
and i can take them out of what i call
their loop so
anybody that's done enough podcasts
especially somebody doing a book
they have a loop they have like tight
talking points you can hear it
in their cadence when they go into their
loop and so i'm like ah
that i hate that it's also boring for me
because i've watched so much content on
them
that i'm like i don't want to be in your
loop i want to now understand you so
well that we can go somewhere new and so
that's the
the edict that i give myself as i go
into this
cool i've been so i just started
podcasting right i started in
in may and i'd been on other people's
podcasts but it's completely different
because the host just
asks you questions and you don't really
have to do much especially if
me i'm just talking about like myself
right it's it's easy it's not ideas or
anything um
and i've thought and i do background
research on my guests of course but
i've wondered if doing too much and you
obviously haven't found this but i've
been wondering if doing too much reading
on them means that you skip some of the
introductory phase
that your audience might be going
through so i find that if i read like a
number of books that
from somebody i bring on uh sometimes i
won't ask
questions that someone who hasn't read
any of their books would ask
do you have a way of figuring that part
out or do you just not worry about that
i i am wholly uninterested in being the
101 of anybody's story or book
so i when i came into it
because you know what people were
telling me when i first started doing a
podcast was thomas has been played out
um everybody that's going to succeed in
podcasting has already succeeded they're
too big you're never going to be able to
catch up this is not a good use of your
time
and so my obviously my retort at that
time was there's always room for the
best
so i came into this saying i have to be
better than everybody else and so how am
i going to differentiate myself
and once you start researching somebody
you realize they give the same interview
over and over and over so once you've
seen like one interview with that person
is going to be the same
interview everywhere and so what i want
to do is say
hey those interviews already exist boys
and girls i'm not
the interviewer for you if that's what
you want go watch another one of those
youtube videos what i'm going to do
is pick up on okay this is you've got
this thing i'm we're gonna sort of
tightly compact it for people and then
we're gonna go into the most interesting
and usable stuff
so usability became my obsession what in
their book can you
take into your own life and apply right
now today
that's the most helpful part really i
think so but look it's
it'd be interesting to compare views
right like
does somebody who does the 101s do they
trounce me
in views they might so it's depending on
what your end goal is
it may or may not be the right choice
but my end goal
is i want to make sure
that people go through that mindset
transformation so
that they are shaping their mind in such
a way that they're capable of
accomplishing whatever it is that they
want to accomplish
and each of these people has some nugget
to offer um
but somebody has to do the you know the
the phd level that's very complimentary
of myself somebody has to do a higher
level interview than just the sort of
introductory one-on-one and that's the
gap i'm trying to fill
cool okay i like that uh back to
structuring your life how is it because
i said how is it that you're on this
podcast right now because i feel like
i'm running around like a chicken with
his head cut off
all the time and then whenever i'm like
oh a little bit of time then i squish
four projects into it that don't fit and
then i'm like i have no time but
and that's just how i live which i'm
trying to sort out
but how how have you structured your
life do you have a morning routine like
how do you how do you make time for
things how do you figure out
what to do well like like you
it is a bloodbath of the number of
things that i
want to do versus the number of things
that i'm able to do
there's a gross discrepancy that i find
emotionally
distressing and whenever i contemplate
like whoa you could actually look at my
life and say
given how long each of the projects you
care about takes you're only going to
get seven more of them or whatever the
number is done
that that is heartbreaking in a way i
can't explain i try to turn away from
that fact
at all times but what i do to get the
most
out of everything is yes i have a
morning routine
but the morning routine starts the night
before so i'm doing everything i can to
cognitively optimize that's the first
thing so i get
as much sleep as my body will take uh i
eat right i exercise i meditate no
that's basically my
daily routine and then maybe more
importantly
is i always have a list of the important
things that i should be working on so
that i'm never losing time to thinking
about what should i be working on so
when one of those narrow windows open
i have in order exactly what i should be
working on i also have a
vision for the company and my life what
i'm trying to accomplish
and so i know well these projects align
with that these projects do not so
i get offers all the time to you know
join the boards of companies or whatever
that i'm sure are going to go on to be
wildly lucrative
they do not align with what i have
stated i want to accomplish with my life
i know what the mission of my life is i
also know how i plan to
sort of logistically accomplish that
mission and so i just filter every yes
or no decision through
does this move me towards my goals and
so one of the edicts in my life is i
only do
and believe that which moves me towards
my goals
and i'm super ruthless about that um i
know
what fills me because what i'm chasing
ultimately is fulfillment
so what is it that fulfills me so i
carve out a tremendous amount of time
to love my wife to be with my wife
and but i segment that so that's the
weekend
during the week monday through friday if
i'm awake i'm either working or working
out
and i hold true to that if like as i was
setting up the lights for this podcast i
was reading a book
right as i'm cooking food i'll be
reading a book cause i'm eating food
i'll be reading a book
i don't have sex during the week which
i'm sure will freak some people out
um and then on the weekends it shifts
and on the weekends
my primary objective is my marriage and
so while i still work
if i was working and my wife came in and
said hey i really want to spend i know
this is supposed to be what we call
selfish time
but i really need to connect right now i
would drop whatever i was doing and hang
out with my wife
and honestly she's so good about
knowing sort of the the full gestalt of
what we're trying to accomplish if she
came to me on a tuesday
and was like hey for real you know i
don't abuse this but i need your time
right now i would stop whatever i'm
doing
because my highest priority is my
marriage so everything else has to find
its way around my marriage
but i have found that when you don't
have kids first of all so that makes it
a lot easier
your spouse is also your business
partner so everything you guys do is
already intertwined you know intimately
the details of each other's lives so
you're not feeling like
the harder i work the more distant you
become it's like the harder i work the
more it's
helping this thing that we're growing
together she fully understands it if i
say what project i'm working on she's
like oh yeah i get that i understand why
it's important
all of that helps and then just having
time
where you're spending quality time
together in a way that the other person
understands
so and one great benefit of my
particular wife's mentality is for her
a lot of times simply sharing space to
her is
is what she would call quality time so
like last night
i was reading literally till the moment
i went to bed but i had her sit between
my legs and i gave her a back rub and
just
something that i know she loves while
she was unwinding for the night
and so i'm you know effectively doing
double duty if i'm listening to an
audiobook
which by the way if i ever say read i
mean listen to um
if i'm listening to an audiobook i
actually prefer to be
doing something you know but mindless
washing dishes taking the trash out
brushing my teeth whatever so that my my
body has its thing to do
and then my mind can totally focus on
the book and so
being present with her touching her um
you know sharing that space with her is
incredibly meaningful to the
relationship
but also i'm able to take in that other
information
but on the weekends then i'm like no
[ __ ] double tasking
like set it all down it's her and i
locked in a universe talking hanging out
watching something and just really
relishing in what it means to share
a life with somebody that's very
interesting
okay i've got a whole bunch of questions
off of that um
how much sleep do you get on average i'm
aiming for seven but usually it's more
like five and a half to
six oh okay and you can operate at that
yes i could operate forever and never
miss a beat at six hours a night
if i'm below six hours a night for say
two or three days in a row i can feel it
and so but that's pretty rare that i'll
spend that many nights in a bad cycle
it's normally six
i'm pretty pretty good there and then
every now and then i'll be like whoa i
just slept eight hours
um so yeah on on that front while if i
could snap my fingers i would be a
better sleeper
um i don't have a lot of complaints okay
and
exercise and diet how how much do you
exercise you said do you exercise daily
i exercise five days a week um
i'm not so like my wife is a beast in
the gym and i went through probably a
10-year period where
the gym was one of my highest priorities
and it was a lot of fun and my physique
was amazing
but when i think about what i'm trying
to accomplish i've always resented the
gym i don't like having to work out i
like the results
um so but i probably spend about 30 to
40 minutes
in the gym a day five days a week okay
and what's your diet look like
whole foods whenever possible um very
clean i am high fat low carb moderate
protein
um i eat a lot of red meat uh i ate
vegetables
but uh i don't go harder people eat
vegetables
well i went through a phase where i
didn't touch vegetables
so i i have i have experimented with
many
many a diet and my wife has had i mean
look to anybody other than you
i would say my wife has had the most
debilitating
diet-related problems i've ever seen in
a human being terrible
to the point where there was a time
where i was like is she gonna survive
like it legitimately got terrifying um
but that forced us to learn a lot about
the microbiome and you know that it
really does matter
what food your food ate
which you could not have convinced me of
seven years ago i've been like the [ __ ]
out of here that doesn't make sense
uh and now i'm like no no you don't have
to tell my wife anything
if that cow ate grain she will have a
massive reaction and are you serious
yeah yeah
okay so between grass-fed and grain fed
oh definitively really
aggressively it was her hair was falling
out
her nails were brittle she couldn't keep
anything down that that's when i was
like
you really can die from malnutrition
even though you're trying to eat
um she wants to put you're going to
think i'm exaggerating i promise you i'm
not like
four flakes four flakes of pepper on a
dish
and we were minutes from going to the
emergency room because she was doubled
up on the floor in agony four
hours and
working our way back out of that was a
probably
four years until she was good she still
there's certain things she just cannot
touch
um there was a time where if she had had
a bite
of grain-fed beef she would have had a
problem now if she had grain fed she'd
be like okay i noticed the difference
but she's built up a resilience
i don't think she has leaky gut anymore
i think that's the big thing
um but that was that was insane it is so
complicated the microbiome immune
reactions
it's like well talk about something that
even
after as many years as i put into
reading researching
interviewing people and then having a
human to experiment on
it's still just dizzyingly complicated
yeah it's very frustrating ah and i i
had similar
reactions to pepper too i was like if i
have reason i can't i couldn't cook a
steak
i didn't actually have that i noticed
that dramatic
of a reaction to grain fed i ate mostly
grain fat i didn't seem to have problems
thank goodness but if i had a steak
cooked on a grill and the grill had
seasoning from other steaks and they
hadn't cleaned it well enough
i'd have an autoimmune reaction it's
like how am i supposed to live like this
but i did
i did get a lot better um so thank
goodness for that but i'm sorry about
your wife that is
not fun but you definitely learn a lot
when it's like death
or learning very true
yeah um oh okay you mentioned so we
covered
diet exercise so what your kind of
lifestyle looks like
you said you consume most of your books
all of your books by listening to them
yeah unless the person so when i'm
interviewing people a lot of times
there's no audio version yet so they'll
send me a physical version
but i try to do that as rarely as
possible because i'm just a
ridiculously slow reader okay so that's
why
i found um i thought if i could like do
dishes or
cook although i don't spend very much
time cooking but uh
if i could do something while i'm
listening to audiobooks i could just
listen to audiobooks all the time and i
could get so
much information and i can't do that
as soon as i look at something i don't
know if i'm just not trained properly or
if that's not how my brain works or what
but if i'm doing something
i start thinking about something else or
thinking about what i'm doing or
thinking about anything
while i'm listening to it and i can just
i just stop hearing it
so the only way i've been able to get
information is by
looking at words it's really not
convenient
it might be worth trying so i have
learned there are certain things that i
can't do while i'm listening to an audio
book so for instance i can't pick
clothes and listen to a book because i
have to make decisions about the clothes
so i found that whoa i stopped paying
attention
but anything like washing dishes there's
no decisions to be made cooking
for me that's i eat the same thing all
the time so
i spend as little time preparing food as
humanly possible i've done it so many
times
there's literally no decisions to be
made so i can listen during that eating
for sure
moving around the house i always keep
headphones on me
put before i get up to pee for instance
i will put headphones in hit play on the
book
which will my phone will default show me
as soon as i pick up my phone it
defaults to the book
and then you just hit play and boom you
go do your thing so even if i'm walking
around the house
you know let's say for 60 seconds
because i listen to a novel at 2.3 speed
non-fiction at 3x um you know you're wow
one one minute becomes almost two and a
half minutes of book reading
and i have found that in 10 days
i average 24 hours of reading time
just because you're moving around i'm
working out in the gym i'm listening
um moving around the house setting up
the lights for the podcast
feeding the dogs feeding myself like
there's just giving my wife a back rub
there there are
so many things that you do in a day that
for me i find it very easy to listen as
long as there's no decision that i have
to make
okay that's interesting i feel like i'm
not trying hard enough to be honest
because even if i'm at the gym if i'm
listening to a podcast like i can't
listen to podcasts because i start
thinking about something else
it feels like a self-discipline problem
to be honest i'm pretty sure it is
it could also be some priority like in
the gym
my wife wouldn't be able to listen to a
book because she's
so focused on working out doing it as
good as she can focusing on the muscle
groups and i'm like
i hate that i have to do this i'm just
trying to get this done the only way
that i can justify spending
a half an hour of my time doing
something like this is if i can read
so would my physique be better if i
didn't read in the gym
definitively it's just not a trade-off
i'm willing to make
okay i feel like i'm just i'm on the
on your side with working out and
spending time working out and then your
wife's side of also not being able to do
anything
while i'm doing it so that's not that's
not very useful
uh you mentioned you don't have kids are
you planning on having kids no no
no no why um you know it's interesting
the only human being in the world that
ever got me to contemplate it was your
dad
and the reality is here is the truth of
kids for me
i could write you a poem michaela that
would make you believe to the core of
your bones
that i know what it means to have a
child so this is not something i'm doing
blindly a big brother for a kid for
eight and a half years
trust me when i say that it was a deep
relationship
that involved him having to i had to
help him through
out of the adoptive home he was in and
into the court system and i was
very involved in this kid's life so i
got a real taste of what it would be
like to be
somebody's parent and it is beautiful
and it
gives you something that is hard to
understand unless you've ever
tasted that now whatever amount i know i
know that
actually having a child is a thousand
times more powerful than that
so if i had a kid i'm sure that i would
be captured emotionally the same way
everyone else is
so it's not like i fear walking that
road i think that that road has
beautiful things built into it and if
that had been the path i walked then it
would have made all the sense in the
world
but i have goals
that i want to give myself to completely
and when a goal is both exciting and
honorable meaning it truly excites me
just the thought of doing it the being
in the trenches every day working on it
is
thrilling and it doesn't just uplift me
it uplifts
other people then i think you get that
fulfillment that you would otherwise get
from having a child
so i got really good advice about having
kids when i was still contemplating it
and the guy said look tom have kids
don't have kids but whatever you do
do it all the way i thought that is very
good advice
so my wife and i are ex we've been
married for 20 years sorry we've been
together for 20 years
um and married for 18 and change
and i
am so in love with her and so
enjoy my time with her and want her as
my gravitational center
and i know that having kids i would have
a new gravitational center and rightly
so
um just wasn't something that i wanted
to do even
and and here's sort of the ultimate
thing that i will say and then i will
leave this subject
um when i'm on my deathbed
i will definitively regret not having
children
i just believe to the core of my being
that i would regret having children
now so it is a trade-off that i'm
willing to make i can step into the
frame of reference of being at the end
of my life and not having anything
that will survive me and knowing how
hard evolution pushes you
to feel the weight of progeny carrying
you into the future
and i will feel that and that loss will
hurt
um i'm just not willing to give up 20
years of like
relentlessly focused time with my wife
and what we're building and the person
that i want to become
um to spread my energies across yet
another thing
though it would inevitably bring me joy
yeah okay i get that i had a lot i had
so i have a toddler uh she's three and a
half
and i always knew i i mean my dad is my
dad and he talks about family all the
time so
it wasn't just that i always knew i
wanted to have a family but i'm i'm so
work oriented that uh
it was really difficult especially the
first year
i i think it's i think it's worth it
hands down
but the first year was my entire focus
everything i did was based around a baby
and and it's for sure the first year and
then it it's after that is
it's after that two but for the first
year it's entirely the baby and your
relationship goes to the side
as well after that i think it's better
to make sure that
the person you're in a relationship with
is the focus and then you also have
children
um but yeah what
what's changed my mind was thinking
about i've talked to old people
i guess you can call them old people
that's still okay but uh i've talked to
a lot of older people and
and the biggest regret i've heard was i
wish i had more kids
and i thought there's so much time
commitment into having children now
especially
when you're at peak career and it does
take time
um so i've been speaking to a lot of
people who have some really successful
people who have
three or four kids and i'm like well how
is that possible like is one of you
staying at home and
sacrificing their career for it and a
lot of the times
yes so one half of the relationship is
staying at home
um or they hire people and so then they
have
other people doing the majority of the
child care
um and that allows them to be business
owners
and have kids but there isn't uh from
what i've seen especially with really
like c-suite level people i guess
um you either sacrifice somebody to
having children at least for that period
of time and
that does mess things up career-wise
or you hire people um and then
i guess that would go against the being
all in although i've seen people manage
it
and i have a nanny at the moment so
which
filled me with an incredible amount of
guilt really
why i don't understand that well
um i i grew up and my dad my mom was a
stay-at-home mom
and my dad kind of i would say strongly
encouraged that
and i tried doing that for about
a year in a bed and i was just like
wilting
um because i didn't have the time to do
anything that i liked i'm
extremely like what makes me happy is
doing work
uh and i was just like i can't i'm
staying home i'm doing like laundry i'm
cooking i'm cleaning and i'm doing
housewife things i'm taking care of a
baby who i absolutely love
but all the opportunity i can see flying
by
is killing me and my husband was like
well we can
my husband's russian so he wanted our
kid to grow up speaking russian so he's
like well we'll get a russian
nanny don't don't worry about it right
there wasn't a
it wasn't like he was pushing anything
on me he was like i just want you to be
happy
um and i ended up talking to my aunt
and she's a nurse like a head nurse a
nurse practitioner
and she has three kids and
she had a nanny and she said yeah like
there was a trade-off i chose
my career my kids loved me they liked
watching
a woman succeed um when i when i spent
time with them i was happy about the
time i spent with them but it wasn't all
my time
and so i made a decision and i was like
you know what i want kids i want more
than one kid
um so i'm gonna have multiple children
but i can't sacrifice
my career and what i want to do without
wilting so
i'll find people i trust to help me
raise kids and then i tried to like i
was like okay how is that okay
because there's some social stigma with
that still
and i thought going back um going back
to when we kind of lived in more tribes
your kids wouldn't necessarily be raised
solely by you
there were grandparents and aunts and
uncles and cousins and older siblings
and nowadays it's so difficult because
it's just you guys
um so i get i get where you're coming
from
yeah i just i don't find the social
stigma around a lot of things very
compelling and
on that one i really don't find that
compelling people are perfectly happy to
send their kids to school
which is the school is going to have
such a tremendous impact on your child
um
so yeah having a nanny somebody to help
if you're denying your child
love that's a whole different thing but
yeah if you're loving the life out of
your kid and they have no doubt that you
love them
and you're putting in time which is
absolutely required and doing it
joyfully and with presents like
yeah i don't see the problem yeah and
the worst thing you
you can have too and you've seen this in
families especially if you have a
stay-at-home mom
or stay-at-home dad but stay-at-home mom
is you get someone who's
sacrificed and they're angry about it
and then you end up with a resentful
parent at the kid and it's
not the kid's fault and so i was at home
and i wasn't
i wasn't getting resentful at the kid
but i was kind of getting resentful at
andre
and i was just like this is not it's not
working there's got to be a way that i
can be happy that i can
you know that things are different and
i'm i'm totally fine with that i'm happy
about it now but
it was difficult to make that decision
so
i get where you're coming from it's a
very tricky thing to do especially when
you have
a whole bunch of opportunity and and
goals that are really working out and
filling you with happiness
no question okay i'm gonna ask one more
question
and then i'll let you go how do you oh
well you've met you've uh uh you've
answered the
work and rest you kind of take two days
off
ish yeah the way to think about work and
rest for me because i do work on the
weekends
my average week is pro my average week
is probably 90 hours 85 to 90 hours my
average i routinely pop over 100 if
something really has to get done
the key is to structure your life in
such a way
that the work is joyful
so the reason that i so when my wife and
i exited our last company
we never needed to work again ever i
mean just
never had to think about money again and
we thought okay
what we want to do though is really do
something gives us meaning and
significance
so let's build something if we're if
we're going to work when we don't have
to let's make sure that what we build is
something that
that fills us in ways that we can't
explain and
for me storytelling has always been just
a calling i love it so much and i cannot
tell you how much i love writing
so jeff bezos very aptly said
that in any job no matter how much you
love it there's a certain amount of
overhead
things you don't like doing so monday
through friday i'm doing my overhead
when i work on the weekends
with precious few exceptions it's never
overhead
it's writing it's editing a story it's
looking at concept art it's
you know doing things that have to be
done for the business but also
in and of themselves i find so
energizing and exciting
that it's arguably the best way that i
could spend that's why
it i do it during my selfish time so my
wife and i take selfish time she draws
she's a world-class artist
absolutely breathtaking and i will write
or do something around the stories
and that to me is is incredible so
it's a lot of hours for work but like
they say if you love what you do you'll
never work a day in your life
so that's how i'm able to hit the kind
of crazy numbers that i hit
or the number of books that i read it's
like i love that [ __ ] it lights me on
fire i'm excited to do it i'm not
trudging through it
okay um i'm actually gonna sneak one
more please in here
how do you so you run a large company um
how do you figure out when you're not
the person for the task you're doing and
you should hire somebody
if you're truly obsessed obsessed
with accomplishing your goal that
becomes very easy to see
and then if you create because if i
really like i'm really trying to build
the next disney
and if that's just rhetoric and
something i want to say in a podcast to
sound cool
then i'll make a lot of dumb decisions
because then it's ego and all that but
if i'm really like no no
that's actually what i want to do i want
to play my role in building that thing
then you are going to desperately look
for the people that can do the things
that you can't do
and again because i don't pride myself
on being good smart right any of those
things
i pride myself on identifying the right
answer so the very thing that gives me
self-esteem
is going i don't know this but they do
and now i'm going to champion them i'm
going to celebrate them i'm going to
lift them up
and then this gets more now into just
like true business acumen
you've got to create a culture where
people are not even courage where it is
demanded
that they speak up if they have a better
answer people have a
really hard time speaking to power so we
work with
i don't know if you know ray dalio wrote
a book called principles he's created an
app called the dot collector which
allows you to rate people in real time
and a bunch of different attributes
and we use that like like our life
depends on it here at impact theory
because i've run the experiment of what
happens when you have a normal business
environment where
it's like yeah you know you try to get
along and you know be honest enough and
don't be a dick and that
that spirals into madness as you scale
faster than you can imagine which is why
most people hate their jobs
because they're surrounded by a bunch of
frenemies where it's just backbiting
gossipy
we don't [ __ ] tolerate that [ __ ] at
impact theory
own it speak up or get out that's our
mantra if you
if you have a criticism about somebody
that you are prepared to take to your
grave to never even tell your
significant other
at impact theory you have an obligation
to say it to that person's face
period if you can't do that get the [ __ ]
out i am
no way that's why we have unusually low
turnover
you say the hard things you hear the
hard things now when you have an
organization like that where when
and this has actually happened an intern
will call
me out the ceo in front of the entire
company and say i don't think you're
thinking about this right
and here's why i think you're wrong and
i say thank you tell me more
because if that person actually has the
right answer that's actually going to
let me build disney
because i pride myself in that moment
for saying thank you tell me more
like that actually yes i'm doing
something other people can't do other
people have egos they get in the way but
my ego is built maniacally around
my willingness to listen to this person
any person that might have a key insight
and then to celebrate them and say they
came up with this idea this is their
idea
which you do because selfishly that's
how you get more good ideas because when
people know that you're not going to
steal it from them you're going to
celebrate them you're going to be the
energy behind that idea
and then you do that then you can
actually make progress
so but creating that culture is so
[ __ ] hard
humans want to retreat they don't want
to say hard things yeah and because
i tend to attract other pleasers because
i love to see people happy
i attract other pleasers so for us it
isn't hearing the hard things
our team is more than prepared to hear
hard things
our team has a hard time saying hard
things
so we have to actually make as a part of
our weekly
meeting we carve out time for people to
go
and voice publicly or
in the dot collector which is public but
it gives them a little bit of
buffer any concerns criticisms beefs
that they have whatever
it has been incredible and the people
that don't like doing it self-select
and and they leave that is
such valuable information thank you
thank you very much
uh where where can people find you
online if they're not following you
already
at tom billy man at tom bilyeu i'm at
tombowview everywhere
um instagram twitter youtube is really
my big platform
and then michaela if any of the people
listening to this happen to be into
storytelling
uh we also are very active on webtoon
we have two webtoon comics that are live
there now that we're also trying to
translate into either anime or live
action
um which is the future of impact theory
so
anybody that wants to self select their
way there we also have a discord channel
for impact theory
that is focused on storytelling well
thanks again tom
thank you for having me on
you